okay nice excited to be here glad
looking forward to talking to all you
about Gatsby
so first show of hands who here has
heard of Gatsby before okay it's a solid
majority who here is used it in some
fashion another cool it's about half of
people awesome
so um let's jump in okay so first the
kind of basic definition Gatsby is a
free and open-source web framework based
on react that helps developers build
blazing-fast websites and apps and our
goal is that you can approach building
you know whatever you wanted to use
build with react on the web with
confidence and kind of the idea is you
know reacts when it was introduced was
famously like hey we're just a view and
largely speaking that's true like it's a
incredible library but you know the
number of concerns that react covers is
relatively small and Gatsby's goal is to
kind of help you with everything else
need to build a great website or app for
the web it's a bit about me so I'm the
founder of the Gatsby open source
project and also Gatsby is now a company
and so I'm the CEO there and my
background is pretty CMS heavy I build a
lot of sites with Drupal is like a
freelancer in the 2000s and then kind of
2010's I worked at Pantheon a start-up
in San Francisco on a Drupal WordPress
kind of developer tools hosting company
and after doing a lot of CMS stuff a lot
of kind of I do a lot of backbone jQuery
exedra back in the day I got into react
and I wanted to start Gatsby because I
fell in love with react and I wanted to
have a simple way to take react and the
kind of the paradigm I loved there and
use it to build websites and I open
source that and now four years later
there's tens of thousands of you know
sites and apps built with Gatsby and a
really thriving ecosystem of
contributors
so you know there's a number sites
you've probably seen that building got
to be including the react Docs also like
impossible foods and a bunch of other
sites you can check them out at the
showcase and give you start with Gatsby
super simple it's three steps install
the COI and then you do gatsby new to
create a new site and there's kind of a
default starter and then there's
hundreds of starters that the community
has created
it's got to be can be used for all sorts
of different things like e-commerce
blogs portfolio sites marketing sites
almost anything you can imagine and yeah
and then there's a developer server got
to be developed so let's actually jump
in and see what it's like so go to a
command line like that's odd
yeah I ran get clean that was missing
okay
luckily the the way the conference Wi-Fi
is pretty fast okay so start the Gatsby
develop command and it goes through the
bootstrap process it starts web pack dev
server I think a little bit bigger still
ok and then we have a bug very nice so
this is the this is the official blog
starter by the way okay so this is a
react app run by Gatsby and I can click
around it has pages these pages are
created from markdown files so if you
kind of look at that was too much so
these are all unlike the the content
folders or content blog if we open up
our editor I make this bigger too so if
we open up Dennis fun okay if we open up
our editor to you know new beginnings
you can see the same markdown file say
new beginnings in Prague you can save it
hot reloads you change the date to you
know today happy Halloween
voila come change it up there so you get
a hot reloading for I'm going one of the
goals that Gatsby is is hot reloading is
good everything hot reloads so this is a
markdown file you can go to other
markdown files and then I Chloe world or
actually you know so this be the world
hello world your Great Neck said yeah I
think their egos so Gatsby has the idea
of there's there's two ways to kind of
add pages there's kind of like
standalone pages so like the home page
here is driven by this react component
and then each of the blogpost pages are
a template component like this so if we
go here to the title and we're like the
title say that you know then it updates
the template you know for all the
different blog posts like so yeah and so
gatsby it uses react obviously and it
also uses graph QL to kind of fetch the
data that's needed for all these pages
and so you can use that you can fetch
data from all sorts of places so this
site uses markdown but gatsby supports
like hundreds of different sources like
basically anything with an API you can
pull in data from and the Gatsby
community has created a bunch of source
plugins to do this which all used kind
of Gatsby's graph cue layer so this is
like the graphical query for the blog
post template so kind of a simple thing
you can do is you know this fetches the
date from the markdown field and then
you can like format the date so if we
change that for example then it modifies
how we are rendering the year I think so
and if you use graph QL you've probably
seen the graphic yuo which is the the
built-in graph QL IDE and that we
include that with gasps because it's
super useful for kind of working you
know figuring out what query you need so
a typical pattern is and you're like I
need a new page and then you play around
in graphic UL to figure out what the
query you need and then you create the
page and so gatsby tries to make that
really simple so over here you can see
all the different kind of types that are
included and each each each each type
has sort of a collection a way of
clearing the whole collection so for
example if you wanted to query every
markdown file you could click on all
markdown remark and then you click on
notes and then you're like I want to get
the excerpts
and frontmatter title and then time to
read and then you come over here and you
click the run and then that returns the
data so you can see like my second pose
new beginnings in Prague etc etc and
this is all live so it's like we change
and if you change the markdown then the
query get whatever and then we've
included this code exporter so you know
you want to create a new page that's
showing these you just copy this
generated page query and then what you
can do is you want to say let's say you
want to go my new page and then Gatsby
will say oh hey there's no no pages oh
yeah but it tells you how to create it
so if you create a react component at
source pages my new page then this will
show it so we can go pages my new page
yes and then we just save this and okay
there you go and then you know you can
like start modifying this you like
my blog post cetera and then let's say
you wanted to link this from the home
page should go back here go here and so
Gatsby includes a link component which
is already imported on the index
component from Gatsby and so just after
the bio for example you do link to link
to that page my new page and then and
then voila you've add a new page to your
site he'll jump back in yeah so earlier
I said you know if react is just a view
Gatsby is everything else so what is the
everything else that got to be adds to
wrecked yes the first thing is you know
to build you know to actually take your
react components and like build them
into a form that you can deploy
somewhere you need a bundler you need
transpire you need probably support for
typescript support for CSS options a
bunch of other stuff and gatsby provides
you know all these by default we have
like a kind of a really bulletproof
config that the vast majority of sites
use and that we've extensively tested
you know so that's like as reliable
robust as fast as possible cetera and
then as you probably know web pack has a
you know a bunch of different ways of
modifying it and we've wrapped all these
in gatsby plugins which there's now 1400
of them so that almost any imaginable
type of modification you want to make to
your build setup you just install the
plug-in and off you go
another great thing about Gatsby is
hosting is really simple
what Gatsby you know gatsby sites don't
require servers to run them which means
that instead of like having to provision
and set up a bunch of sites you can just
use a kind of a static hosting provider
like the CDN and run it for a fraction
of cost of runtime SSR site
which is great because you know CDNs are
that's their whole job is to serve lots
of you know files really fast and so
when your entire sites on a CDN it
solves a whole bunch of problems around
running your site so in general you know
we say you should prefer kind of like
serverless solutions like gatsby does
where you kind of pre render your react
up versus runtime SSR which is much more
complex and costly kind of a simple
example of this is Harry's comm which is
a Shafer branch site they launched a new
women's brand and on launch day they
built their new site with Gatsby and a
launch day they got 10x their normal
traffic and there and then they told us
that they were you know nervous like oh
like anything gonna break something to
happen whatever and they didn't have to
do anything they had it on fastly and
the site scaled without any problems and
it was really kind of peaceful
they just got still just be excited and
I watch it nothing gets me covers is SEO
so as you probably know react you know
purely client-side apps have Google and
others have trouble parsing those and so
gatsby SSRS pages at built time so that
your site is index you know as expected
another great thing gatsby does is
loading data is kind of surprising to me
that yeah just like how much time just
getting data onto a page can take it's a
remarkably complex problem and gatsby
goes to great lengths to kind of
automate that so as we saw earlier with
like kind of the graph Coulier and you
can hook up plug-ins for almost any sort
of data source to pull in data and then
gatsby automates loading that into the
page and so with a data layer you have
essentially no boilerplate where you
just have your component and then your
query and then we handle loading it in
when it's needed another great thing
about Gatsby is performance is baked in
so performance is like a whole bunch of
little things to to get right stuff like
code splitting image optimizations
inlining critical styles lazy loading
prefetching eccentric cetera et cetera
and we spend a ton of time just like
researching like what are the best
practices and finding ways to
automatically make that happen within
gots me so that all you have to do is
like react components and then we'll
take care of making sure that that's
fast without manual tuning which a lot
of systems require so kind of a quick
demo this like if you go to got to be
jeaious tight org and then if you load
up the network tab so I talked about
like prefetching for example and like
loading data so one thing that got sweet
does is you know as you kind of like
start rolling so when these kind of like
links come up we start pre fetching the
data needed for them so now when you
like click on this for example
everything needed to render that page is
already in the client because we
prefetch them so kind of show that again
as we scroll down and start to get in
here some links you know we pulling
these page data for you know like page
data ecosystem click on that you know
instantly renders the new page because
the data and the code has already been
pre fetched and so by taking like an
entire site and then like kind of like
breaking up into little chunks and makes
sure that you know you're never loading
too much when the page first loads but
by intelligently prefetching as soon as
you want to go to a link you know your
user isn't waiting for that to happen
okay so how does got to be happen it's
not just me sneak peek so two years ago
so I started the project four years ago
and open sourced it and was really
gratified by just the really strong
interest from you know react developers
are on the road
and I knew that like I've done open
source for a long time and you know
those of you who participate heavily an
open source you know it can be sometimes
a thankless task like you you know you
have your job and then you have your
other job you don't maintain the open
source project and I knew that Gatsby
had the potential to be like a really
massive project and I knew it wasn't
something I could do by myself
and so I wanted to make sure that Gatsby
had like a strong kind of like business
model behind it so that both myself and
other people that would you know be
needed to to kind of work on the project
what could have salaries to like work
full-time on it it wasn't like a
part-time thing yeah because I think you
know great great open-source software
requires a lot of dedicated time to make
happen and so my co-founder Sam Bhagwan
died we a couple years ago we started to
found that our started a startup founded
to startup - to help grow Gatsby and we
raise money in order to do that so so
far we've raised eighteen point seven
million from a few different VC firms
and there's now 40 full-time got to be
employees with 15 of those working
full-time on OSS and we're seeking to
model ourselves after there's been a
number of great OSS companies emerged
over the last few years like elastic
confluent hashey cork and a bunch of
others and what they've done is you know
married building an amazing inclusive
OSS ecosystem and providing also like
cloud services with lots of customers to
kind of like fund the whole thing and
our goal is that you know with the
community that everyone feels like they
belong that you know it's a you know we
we go to great lengths to provide great
documentation so like anybody can get
started with gatsby and we also you know
try to you know enforce code of conducts
we have commits to accessibility and do
a lot of things so that people can get
started with gatsby can contribute and
feel safe and you have been really
gratified to see all the people that you
have gotten involved and made great
contributions yeah and so I kind of
recovered that so we're investing
a lot of money to grow Gatsby and we
think that like the this marriage
between OSS and commercial can create
kind of like a virtuous cycle that you
know the the revenue from the business
can fund development and then kind of
the things that we learn through through
you know participation OSS community it
can feed a lot of what we're doing with
the company and that these can really
complement a few each other so a common
question I get asked is like well okay
so your business like how does it
actually work like how do you make money
what's your business model and the
answer is basically you know cloud
infrastructure and collaboration tools
so this is very similar in a lot of ways
what we're doing to like site or notify
Heroku AWS you've kind of other like
cloud technology providers but
specifically for gatsby and you know
we're in process of launching stuff but
we'll have like a generous free tier for
everyone to use and you know for
experimentation small sites and then
charge commercial users as they kind of
scale up their usage of the cloud tools
and so our first product has been out in
open beta for a few months it's called
CMS preview and this is basically
content hot reloading for content
authors and marketers so if you know how
useful it is like while you're
developing code to see hot reloading the
same thing is true of you know for
content authors because like if you're
editing like a con a complex data model
it's nice to see how its kind of affect
the site so let me give a quick demo of
that so this is our dashboard here and
so you can open up hopefully this is
working okay so I need to do this real
quick
too many tubes there's okay so if you
like you edit the title for example is
this okay it's working in Prague so yeah
so imagine you're a content editor and
you're just going around the site and
you're like okay I want to edit a
project not at the London gets me Meetup
[Music]
it's reactive and then you can say
uploaded different images just
screenshots you know so it's like huh
kind of like live reloading as you go
yeah and so we have like 60 ish
customers now so people using gatsby
sites and they want to give their you
know kind of CMS authors a great
experience
okay so close that and then we're also
working to solve kind of build time
build time for sites or building sites
and particularly around how to make
gatsby scale to very large sites and if
you've used gatsby particularly for you
know thousand sites with thousands of
pages like build times can get slow and
what this means is that it can both be
like annoying to use if your site's
larger but also maybe just like
straight-up impossible like you know if
you have a site that has say a hundred
thousand pages it's just not possible to
kind of like pre-render that entire site
in any reasonable amount of time
but we're working to solve that and this
is super hard problem it's kind of a lot
of people say it's like the holy grail
of static sites but we're feeling pretty
confident we've cracked it the basic
idea is you know gatsby like all built
processes you have like a bunch of work
and you do it sequentially and the idea
of what we're doing what we're building
in our and our cloud product is we take
that build process and kind of like
split it apart and run it across
hundreds of servers
so you know the sort of illustration of
the difference between like a normal
build and a cloud build is who normal
build
it's like sequential step by step by
step and then a cloud build we paralyze
stuff immediately and then in subsequent
builds we can like eliminate doing a lot
of kind of like repetitive work because
like we'll have a really fine grain
caching so that we only have to do the
build steps that are necessary which is
like leads to a dramatic speed-up and
this will be part of will be like a
hosted service you know running on a
cloud infrastructure and we'll be
launching this in the coming months
and it's gonna be pretty amazing we
think that yeah well you even very large
sites will rebuild very quickly
yeah and in summary it's like what we're
trying to do in general gatsby gun is
you know help you build you know help
you take react like kind of the paradigm
of react and use it to build any sort of
you know web property with confidence
you know whether that's like kind of
traditional CMS hype websites or like
you know really sophisticated apps you
know gatsby has all the react kind of
you know everything you need around
react to make that happen and
particularly you know we're bringing
react to the CMS world because you know
see most people are still using like
WordPress and Drupal and and and
hundreds of other different you know
different types of CMS's and gatsby lets
you use react with those CMS bolt them
into the modern app world and yeah so
invite you to come build your site's
with got to be thanks for having me
[Applause]
don't go anywhere because a one tile
that you guys are not gonna ask them any
questions since he's the first speaker
and you probably are a little tired
still but that's not true there's so
many of them so could get to be include
type scripts afford by default that's
the first question yeah so that's
something that's requested a lot so
right now Gatsby has a plug-in for
typescript but a lot of people want it
built out of the box and yeah one of our
you know one of the core maintainers is
working on an issue to kind of gather
requirements for that and it's something
yeah we could ship pretty soon actually
how gates we decides how to split code
and when lazy load bundles yeah so we
ship by default page are kind of routes
based code splitting so every like type
of page you know like you know a single
page or like a template page gets its
own bundle and and so those those so
that generally takes care of a lot of
performance problems it kind of like ice
so if you have like a really big
JavaScript template and like one of your
sub pages you know that code that you
need there is only loaded if you visit
that page and you can also do code
splitting like within your page
component if if you want to like lazy
load like a big widget or something that
most people don't need does the
prefetching automatically turn off for
mobile or IA it always on data is not
always cheap yes this is a great point
so we try to be as conservative as
possible we'll still drive in a great
experience
our main solution for this is that most
browsers support like was like a data
saver mode and so we respect that so if
somebody doesn't want to use extra data
then we don't we turn down prefetching a
lot but as you saw in the performance
demo - we only prefetch when we're
pretty confident that somebody is going
to click on the link so generally
speaking we're not loading a lot of data
how about gets being microservices we
support it so
got to be you know fits very well and
kind of like the serverless
microservices paradigm where you have
you know a client app that's talking
into different back-end API s-- so a lot
of people use it very successfully I
mean our you know on Gatsby J's calm
like this is how we're building
everything with microservices we're
gonna do two last questions can you use
Gatsby with rest for dynamic pages with
all the advantages like prefetching yep
absolutely so you know Gatsby's data
layer it's it's pretty straightforward
to hook it up to any sorts of API and
you can trigger building your pages with
that and what are your plans for the new
features and future development of
Gatsby we have tons of plans
yeah I mean we have we have a big team
working on stuff so a lot of our focus
is just in general like improving the
developer experience you know helping
scale up Gatsby builds making your
site's faster and faster so we have a
lot of optimizations coming and what's
cool about what we're doing is that you
know all this is like we're shipping
within you know we've been on like d2
for the last year and we just keep
shipping new improvements so kind of the
overall goal is that you know you start
building your site with Gatsby and then
we'll just make it faster and better as
time goes on well that's all the time we
had for the questions right now but I
will be today at 5 p.m. at the discover
stage as a part of our Ted zone so you
can ask some questions there directly
thank you so much so this was Kyle
Matthews again the creator of Gatsby